This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Hundreds of millions of people have spent the last year waiting. Waiting for it to be safe to enter workplaces. Waiting to see if loved ones will survive their stay in a hospital. Waiting to see if lost jobs will return. Perhaps you have caught yourself daydreaming about the moment everything returns to normal, when we can go about our lives without masks, sit in a crowded theater without worry, meet friends in our homes without fear.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。过去一年里，数以亿计的人们一直在等待。等待着进入工作场所变得安全。等待着看亲人能否在医院的救治中幸存。等待着看失去的工作是否会回来。也许你曾发现自己幻想着一切恢复正常的那一刻：我们可以不戴口罩地生活，可以毫无顾虑地坐在拥挤的剧院里，可以在家中无所畏惧地会见朋友。
What will it feel like that day? Will there be a surge of joy? Or will it be better sweet? This week on Hidden Brain, the agony of waiting and the strange things that happen in our minds when we experience relief. In books and movies, the experience of relief usually follows a period of waiting. We're going to mix up that order on today's show. We'll look at relief first, and later in the show we'll explore the psychology of waiting
那一天的感觉会是怎样的呢？会有一阵狂喜吗？还是会苦乐参半？本周的《Hidden Brain》，我们将探讨等待的煎熬，以及当我们体验到解脱时，大脑中发生的奇妙变化。在书籍和电影中，解脱的体验通常发生在等待之后。在今天的节目中，我们要打乱这个顺序。我们将先谈谈解脱，稍后再探讨等待的心理学。
and what new research reveals about how we can wait well. Our story about relief comes from Jamie Spurway. For five years, Jamie walked as a tour guide, mostly in the Middle East in Europe, but also in South Africa. One of the places he often brought to us was called the Garden Route, where the safaris boast an incredible range of big game. You're seeing an extraordinary array of animals, zebra, giraffe, rhino, hippopotamus, impala. Jamie typically shepherded groups around in land rovers. They were completely open on the sides.
以及关于如何更好地等待，最新研究揭示了什么。我们关于解脱的故事来自杰米·斯珀韦。五年来，杰米一直担任导游，主要在中东、欧洲，也曾在南非工作。他经常带我们去的地方之一叫“花园大道”，那里的野生动物园以种类繁多的大型猎物而闻名。你会看到非凡的动物群：斑马、长颈鹿、犀牛、河马、黑斑羚。杰米通常用路虎车带领游客，车身两侧是完全敞开的。
No glass, no metal, no doors. You just put your hand out and there's air. So you feel close to the animals in a way that is exciting but can also be quite scary at moments as well because there's no sense really of anything in particular protecting you from them. Jamie understood that this thrill was what paying customers were looking for. They wanted to get a feeling of being out in nature, among animals large enough to kill them, but without real risk. The chance an animal would attack was small, but there were occasional reminders that this was not just an excursion to the zoo.
没有玻璃，没有金属，没有车门。你只要把手伸出去，就能触碰到空气。所以你与动物的距离感既令人兴奋，有时也相当可怕，因为你真的感觉不到有什么东西在保护你免受它们的伤害。杰米明白，这种刺激正是付费客户所追求的。他们想要一种置身于大自然中、身处足以致命的动物身旁，却又没有真正危险的感觉。动物袭击的可能性很小，但偶尔的提醒会让你意识到，这不仅仅是一次去动物园的短途旅行。
One of the landraovers that we used had a slightly sort of V-shaped dent in its front where one of the rhino in their park had in the past charged their vehicle and it just shows you the enormous weight of a mountain behind an animal like a rhino that it was able to leave this the significant size dent in the in the front of the car. As a failed safe, Jamie got used to having a rifle on hand for many trips. But not all of them. On one trip in 2005, his company contracted Safari Rangers to help with transportation and security. At the beginning of the trip, Jamie noticed something unusual about the Rangers assigned to his group. In the two parks that we visited in the garden route,
我们使用的一辆路虎车前部有一个V形的凹痕，那是公园里的一头犀牛过去曾冲撞过车辆留下的。这向你展示了像犀牛这样的动物背后那座大山般的巨大重量，它竟然能在车头留下如此明显的凹痕。作为一种安全保障，杰米习惯在许多行程中随身携带步枪。但并非所有行程都如此。在2005年的一次旅行中，他的公司雇佣了野生动物园护林员来协助交通和安保。在行程开始时，杰米注意到分配到他小组的护林员有些不同寻常。在我们访问花园大道的两个公园里，
Safari Rangers didn't have a weapon at all. So it was always in the back of my mind this sense of, okay, I've been trained in recognizing that there may be the need to use a rifle to defend your group of travelers, of tourists, and then in these particular Safari parks, that means of last resort wasn't there. It seemed not necessary to bring this up since the trip was going great.
野生动物园护林员根本没有携带武器。所以我的脑海里一直有一种感觉：好吧，我受过训练，知道在必要时可能需要使用步枪来保护我的游客团队，而在这些特定的野生动物园里，这种最后的手段却不存在。既然旅行进行得很顺利，似乎没必要提起这件事。
No charging rhinos, no rampaging hippos, no need for guns. One day the group was in a safari park. There were too many people to fit into one vehicle, so Jamie split them between two land rovers He rode in one with a driver and a set of parents and their young kids While the rest went in a second land rover. They all had a great time for several hours Finally as the sun was beginning to slip over the horizon It was time for one last animal encounter It was time to see the lions. So we went into the lion
没有冲撞的犀牛，没有横冲直撞的河马，不需要枪支。有一天，团队在一个野生动物园里。由于人太多，无法挤进一辆车，杰米把他们分成了两辆路虎。他与一名司机、一对父母和他们的年幼孩子坐在一辆车里，其余的人则坐进了第二辆路虎。他们愉快地度过了几个小时。终于，当太阳开始滑落到地平线以下时，最后一次动物邂逅的时间到了。是时候去看狮子了。所以我们在黄昏时分进入了狮子
area towards dusk because they're very sleepy during the day but they start to get more active as the sun goes down. The other land rover was just ahead of them when they got to the area with the lions. We pulled up just kind of behind the other vehicle, switched off our engines straight away because that's always the practice as soon as you switch off the engine the animals stop paying any attention to you. And what we were observing at first was, I almost want to say it was flirtation between the alpha lion and a lioness who was on the other side of the fence, so actually in another safari park. And I've never seen a lion behave in the way that this lioness was behaving.
区域，因为它们白天非常嗜睡，但随着太阳下山，它们开始变得活跃起来。当他们到达狮子所在的区域时，另一辆路虎就在他们前面。我们停在另一辆车后面，立即关掉了引擎，因为这始终是惯例——一旦你关掉引擎，动物们就不再关注你了。起初我们观察到的是，我几乎想说那是雄狮首领和围栏另一边（实际上是在另一个野生动物园）的一头母狮之间的调情。我从未见过狮子以这头母狮那样的行为方式行事。
If a lioness could blow kissies, this lioness would have been blowing kissies. She was very clearly flirting, and the alpha male on our side was pacing up and down. It was very clear that he wanted to get through that fence, but there was there was nothing he could do So he was looking very frustrated and in addition to him there's four sub adult males Essentially like a teenager very close to fully grown, but not actually yet a full adult For a while the tourists and the two vehicles sat quietly and watched the lions ignored them They saw tourists come and go every day. The alpha male had by this point wandered off.
如果母狮会飞吻，这头母狮肯定在飞吻。她显然在调情，而我们这边的雄狮首领则在来回踱步。很明显，他想穿过那道围栏，但他无能为力，所以他看起来非常沮丧。此外，还有四头亚成年雄狮，基本上就像青少年，非常接近成年，但还不是完全的成年。有一段时间，游客和两辆车静静地坐着观看，狮子们无视他们，因为它们每天都看到游客来来去去。此时，雄狮首领已经走开了。
I think he'd just got, you know, sick of this, seen as annoyed by the frustration of not being able to get to the other side. If he could go for a cold shower, that's what he would have been a way to do. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha So now all it is is us and these four sub-adult lions, all male as I remember them. And what we were observing was really that they were playing like kittens. And the comparison to kittens, of course, is wrong in the sense of size. I mean, these are very, very much lion-sized kittens, but it looked very, very cute.
我想他只是，你知道，厌倦了这一切，因为无法到达另一边而感到沮丧。如果他能去洗个冷水澡，那正是他想做的。哈，哈，哈……所以现在只有我们和这四头亚成年狮子，据我记忆都是雄性。我们观察到的是，它们真的像小猫一样在玩耍。当然，与小猫的比较在体型上是不对的。我的意思是，这些是非常非常像狮子大小的小猫，但看起来非常非常可爱。
And most of the reactions from my tourists are a remember where they're kind of awe, you know, isn't that adorable to watch what they were doing. And I suspect that we in that moment didn't really even think of them any longer as lions. Eventually, the other Land Rover headed back to base for dinner. But Jamie's group wanted to stay a bit longer to watch the big kitten's play. The kids were excited. It was all very charming. After a while though, people started to get hungry.
我游客的大多数反应都是一种敬畏，你知道，看着它们的行为难道不可爱吗？我怀疑在那一刻，我们甚至不再把它们看作狮子了。最终，另一辆路虎回基地吃晚饭了。但杰米的团队想多待一会儿，看看这些大“小猫”玩耍。孩子们很兴奋。这一切都非常迷人。然而过了一会儿，人们开始感到饿了。
So our guide, who I remember is quite a young man, who maybe in his early 20s, said, okay folks, what do you think? Shall we head back for dinner? The group said, yeah, yeah, okay, let's do that. So he goes to turn on the engine, to turn the ignition. And there's that sound that all of us recognise, but in this moment meant something quite different from usual. So the engine did that noise of it trying to turn over, but it didn't start. And I can't tell you how obvious the impact on the lions was. Suddenly all four of them turn around.
所以我们的导游，我记得他是个很年轻的人，可能才20出头，说：“好吧，各位，你们觉得呢？我们要回去吃晚饭吗？”团队说：“好啊，好啊，好吧，就这样吧。”于是他去发动引擎，转动点火开关。接着出现了我们所有人都熟悉的那种声音，但在这一刻，它意味着与平时完全不同的事情。引擎发出了那种试图启动的声音，但没有发动起来。我无法形容这对狮子的影响有多明显。突然，四头狮子全都转过身来。
Oh! Staring straight at us. Suddenly it goes from adorable and cute and fun and relax to, oh look, they're looking at us. All of a sudden, the open sides of Land Rover, started to fear rather make it. We're in this vehicle, it's open sighted and there's four lions very much intently staring at us. Then the driver did what we were told never ever do, not only did he stand up in the vehicle, he got out of the vehicle and he opens
哦！直勾勾地盯着我们。突然间，气氛从可爱、有趣、放松变成了“哦看，它们在盯着我们”。突然之间，路虎敞开的车身开始让人感到害怕。我们在这辆车里，它是敞开的，有四头狮子正非常专注地盯着我们。然后司机做了我们被告知绝对不能做的事：他不仅站了起来，还走出了车外，打开了
up the hood. And now the lions are pacing towards us. Very slowly but still with absolutely clear intent, they're stalking us, perhaps stalking him. They just look like kittens a few moments before. Now, they looked like adult lions. Like apex predator. Inside the Land Rover, Jamie was feeling increasingly nervous. But he didn't want to communicate his misgivings to the kids. Or even to himself. I think that I was processing it even in the moment as, oh no, this is fine, this is safe,
引擎盖。现在狮子们正向我们踱步而来。非常缓慢，但意图非常明确，它们在跟踪我们，也许是在跟踪他。几分钟前它们看起来还像小猫。现在，它们看起来像成年狮子。像顶级掠食者。在路虎车里，杰米感到越来越紧张。但他不想把自己的不安传达给孩子们。甚至不想传达给自己。我想我当时甚至在处理这种情绪时还在想：哦不，没关系，这是安全的，
and telling myself they're sub-adults, they're not fully grown, and telling myself we're in a vehicle, doing this sort of self-talk that is to keep me just away from the edge of actual terror. from the edge of actual terror. It took a child to voice aloud what Jamie was thinking. The youngest in the group, I remember her really expressing that child's sense of, mommy, daddy, is this okay?
并告诉自己它们是亚成年，还没完全长大，并告诉自己我们在车里，进行这种自我对话，只是为了让我远离真正的恐惧边缘。远离真正的恐惧边缘。直到一个孩子说出了杰米心里的想法。团队里最小的孩子，我记得她真的表达了那种孩子的感觉：“妈妈，爸爸，这样没问题吗？”
That's it, you know, I can see the lion's coming towards us. Jamie tried to keep calm, but his body didn't feel calm. My heart was starting to beat quickly. I was getting that dry mouth, sweaty palms, the stomachs sort of churning. The lions were closing in, scattered in a crescent around the land rover. They were about 25 feet away.
就是这样，你知道，我能看到狮子正向我们走来。杰米试图保持冷静，但他的身体并不觉得冷静。我的心开始剧烈跳动。我感到口干舌燥、手心出汗、胃里翻江倒海。狮子们正在逼近，在路虎周围散开成一个新月形。它们距离我们大约25英尺。
They're low to the ground. Their movements are careful and slow. I mean, we've all seen this in wildlife documentaries. When an animal is stalking its prey, it moves slowly to avoid the risk of startling the prey away, of scaring the prey away. So they're moving very slowly, inching towards us.
它们贴近地面。它们的动作小心而缓慢。我的意思是，我们都在野生动物纪录片中见过。当动物跟踪猎物时，它会缓慢移动，以避免惊动猎物，避免吓跑猎物。所以它们移动得非常缓慢，一点点向我们靠近。
But the gap is constantly closing, and you're seeing, as you're looking out at these lines, increasing detail in their faces. I wouldn't say that I did get the point of seeing the whites of their eyes, but I do remember a sense of just seeing this sort of burning intensity in their eyes, because they were, they didn't, they looked like they weren't blinking sort of burning intensity in their eyes, because they were, they
但距离在不断缩小，当你看着这些狮子时，你会看到它们脸上越来越多的细节。我不会说我看到了它们眼中的白眼仁，但我确实记得看到它们眼中有一种燃烧的强度，因为它们看起来好像没有眨眼……它们眼中有一种燃烧的强度，因为它们
didn't, they looked like they weren't blinking as if everything in their beings was focused on us. Finally, the driver got back in the vehicle. To Jamie, it seemed blindingly obvious what the driver needed to do. Call for help. Like now. So I said to some words along the lines of, so I think it's best just in case, you know, just in case that you contact the base and let them know what's happened.
没有，它们看起来好像没有眨眼，仿佛它们生命中的一切都聚焦在我们身上。最终，司机回到了车里。对杰米来说，司机需要做什么显而易见。寻求帮助。就是现在。所以我说了类似这样的话：“我觉得最好以防万一，你知道，以防万一，你联系基地，让他们知道发生了什么。”
I was trying to pick my words in a way that we convey to him a level of urgency, but not convey to the children the level of anxiety that I was starting to to feel. The driver finally got the hint. He radioed back to base and asked for help. Jamie and the driver and the parents and kids watched the lion slowly close in. It couldn't have taken more than a few minutes, but it felt like an eternity before the other land rover got to them. When he arrived, the driver of the other vehicle revbed his engine
我试图选择措辞，既能向他传达一种紧迫感，又不会向孩子们传达我开始感到的那种焦虑。司机终于领会了暗示。他通过无线电联系基地寻求帮助。杰米、司机、父母和孩子们看着狮子慢慢逼近。这不可能超过几分钟，但在另一辆路虎赶到之前，感觉就像过了一个世纪。当他到达时，另一辆车的司机猛踩油门，
and drove circles around Jamie's Land Rover. This made the lions pull back a bit, but they showed no signs of giving up. They would be scared back and then they would immediately turn around and fix their attention on this again. So it was really not a long-term solution. After a few concentric circles, the other driver pulled up in front of Jamie's Land Rover. Then, both drivers got out of their vehicles and started to attach a tow rope between the Landrovers. So then we've got the same problem. We're back to the beginning because now we've got two people out of the vehicles
绕着杰米的路虎转圈。这让狮子们退后了一些，但它们没有表现出放弃的迹象。它们会被吓退，然后立即转过身，再次将注意力集中在这上面。所以这真的不是长期的解决方案。转了几圈同心圆后，另一名司机停在杰米的路虎前面。然后，两名司机都下了车，开始在路虎之间连接拖车绳。所以我们又遇到了同样的问题。我们回到了起点，因为现在有两个人下了车，
and they're attaching the tow rope between us and the Land Rover in front. The Lions meanwhile were inching ever closer. So by the time both of the drivers got back into their vehicle to start up the engine and try to pull us to safety, they're very close to us, as close as they'd ever been before, but perhaps sort of 10 feet or so away from us. And when the driver in front starts up his engine, thankfully his engine worked fine, and he starts to pull forward to take up the strain between the two vehicles. There's this crack, and it's the tow rope snapping with a strain of trying to pull our
他们正在我们和前面的路虎之间连接拖车绳。与此同时，狮子们正一点点靠近。所以当两名司机回到车里发动引擎并试图把我们拉到安全地带时，它们离我们非常近，比以往任何时候都近，也许只有10英尺左右。当前面的司机发动引擎时，谢天谢地，他的引擎工作正常，他开始向前拉动以绷紧两车之间的绳索。只听“咔嚓”一声，那是拖车绳在试图拉动我们车辆的拉力下断裂的声音。
vehicle. As soon as there's that noise, all four lions sprint towards us. Everyone's screaming, but they run between the two vehicles. They don't come for any of us. The lead lion picks up the tour open his mouth, sprints off into the jungle, and the three other lions follow him. All this happened in seconds. And in those seconds, Jamie and the others experienced a range of emotions. First dread, then terror, and almost instantaneously after the lions disappeared, euphoria.
一听到那个声音，四头狮子全都向我们冲了过来。每个人都在尖叫，但它们从两辆车之间跑了过去。它们没有冲向我们中的任何一个人。领头的狮子叼起拖车绳，冲进了丛林，另外三头狮子紧随其后。这一切发生在几秒钟之内。在那几秒钟里，杰米和其他人经历了一系列情绪。先是恐惧，然后是惊恐，而在狮子消失后几乎瞬间，就是狂喜。
I remember the tension that had been so strong before, just breaking, and suddenly people shifting very quickly from having just screamed a second ago to laughter, because you're still in such an elevated state. There's still so much adrenaline going through your body that I suppose it's not natural to just go, oh, okay, well that's done now. Already, the meaning of what had just happened was changing. I remember having a sense of being physically shaken, as in my hands shaking still from it, but there's just being so quickly a sense of not only are we safe now, but
我记得之前那种强烈的紧张感突然打破了，人们突然从刚才还在尖叫迅速转为大笑，因为你仍然处于那种高度亢奋的状态。你的身体里仍然有太多的肾上腺素，我想，要直接说“哦，好吧，现在没事了”是不自然的。此时，刚才发生的事情的意义已经在改变。我记得有一种身体在颤抖的感觉，我的手还在颤抖，但很快就不仅有一种“我们现在安全了”的感觉，而且
that was already quite a hilarious experience, quite a funny and positive the exciting rather than terrifyingly exciting experience. And really striking how quickly the mood shifted that way. Something else was curious. When the group got back to base and sat down to dinner with the rest of the party, the emotional texture of what happened changed, as the tourists told one another the story. It went from being the most scary part of the trip to being the absolute highlight. People's memory of it was, that was amazing. That was, that was amazing. That was that was fantastic. And actually the other group when we got back
那已经是一次相当滑稽的经历，相当有趣和积极，是令人兴奋而不是令人恐惧的经历。情绪转变之快真是令人震惊。还有一件奇怪的事。当团队回到基地，与其他人一起坐下来吃晚饭时，随着游客们互相讲述这个故事，所发生事件的情感基调发生了变化。它从旅行中最可怕的部分变成了绝对的亮点。人们对它的记忆是：“那太棒了。那太棒了。那太精彩了。”事实上，当我们回到
Safe and sound to the center and had our dinner with them On hearing the stories many of the kids were quite jealous the kids in the other group because they hadn't had this close brush that we'd had The way that we suddenly process it in such a different way is kind of fascinating. How is it a situation can be pure terror and then moments later, a fun story you tell over dinner? What happens in our minds as we brace for the worst and then suddenly find ourselves released from fear. That's when we come back. I remember having a sense of being physically shaken, as it might be, you know, my hands shaking still from it, but there's just being so quickly a sense of not only are we safe now, but that was already quite a hilarious experience, you know, quite a funny and positive the exciting rather than terrifyingly exciting experience.
安全中心并与他们共进晚餐时，听到这些故事，许多孩子感到非常嫉妒，因为他们没有经历过我们那种近距离的接触。我们突然以如此不同的方式处理它的方式真是令人着迷。怎么会有一种情况先是纯粹的恐惧，然后片刻之后就成了晚餐时讲述的有趣故事？当我们为最坏的情况做准备，然后突然发现自己从恐惧中解脱出来时，我们的大脑发生了什么？我们回来后继续探讨。我记得有一种身体在颤抖的感觉，我的手还在颤抖，但很快就不仅有一种“我们现在安全了”的感觉，而且那已经是一次相当滑稽的经历，相当有趣和积极，是令人兴奋而不是令人恐惧的经历。
In the seconds after Jamie's spurways near brush were death, the mood in the land Rover shifted from pure terror to manic laughter. Why does this happen? Psychologist Kate Sweeney has thought a lot about this question. She remembers one time she was driving with family along a steep cliff in Norway. She was in the backseat and at one point, they got dangerously close to the edge. At the very last moment, they pulled back to safety. I started laughing hysterically and emphasis on the hysterical part of it. Obviously nothing about this was at all amusing, and I truly believed any moment that the edge was going to go
在杰米·斯珀韦与死神擦肩而过的几秒钟后，路虎车里的气氛从纯粹的恐惧转变为狂躁的笑声。为什么会这样？心理学家凯特·斯威尼对这个问题思考了很多。她记得有一次她和家人在挪威沿着陡峭的悬崖开车。她坐在后座，有一次，他们危险地靠近了边缘。在最后一刻，他们退回到了安全地带。我开始歇斯底里地大笑，重点是歇斯底里。显然，这根本没什么好笑的，我真的相信任何时刻边缘都会塌陷，
and off we would be. Happily for Kate and her family, the cliff edge held. And as soon as they were down the mountain, Kate felt something nearly identical to Jamie's emotion after his brush with the lions. Euphoria. From the moment we got off of the cliff edge, really through that evening,
我们就会掉下去。幸运的是，凯特和她的家人没有掉下去。当他们下山后，凯特感受到了与杰米在狮子事件后几乎完全相同的情绪。狂喜。从我们离开悬崖边缘的那一刻起，一直到那天晚上，
and really, really for the next few days, we were all just feeling so gleeful that we were alive. And I'm thinking of something that I think is attributed to Winston Churchill at one point. He said, nothing is more exhilarating than to be shot at without effect. And he was talking about going up to the front and feeling bullets whizzing by him, but
真的，在接下来的几天里，我们都感到活着真是太高兴了。我想起了一句据说是温斯顿·丘吉尔说过的话。他说：“没有什么比在被射击而毫发无损更令人振奋的了。”他当时谈论的是去前线，感觉到子弹在他身边呼啸而过，但
not actually getting hit by them. So the sense that you've come close to something terrible, but it hasn't happened, doesn't just leave us feeling, okay, we're fine, let's move on, it leaves us feeling almost exhilarated. What do you think that's about? I think that one of the things that happens when we have a near-death experience is that your physical system, all of your physiology, is on alert. Everything is narrowed, focused, to make sure that you address the threat at hand. Your heart rate is up.
实际上并没有被击中。所以，那种你曾接近可怕的事情，但它没有发生的感觉，并不会仅仅让我们觉得“好吧，我们没事，继续前进”，它让我们感到几乎是振奋人心。你认为这是关于什么的？我认为，当我们有濒死体验时，发生的一件事是你的身体系统，你所有的生理机能，都处于警戒状态。一切都缩小、聚焦，以确保你应对眼前的威胁。你的心率加快。
Everything is amped up on 11. That doesn't just go away once the threat is gone. You kind of have this still very heightened physical and emotional kind of experience that is kind of floating around in your body now without much of a target. And so I think one of the things that seems to happen certainly from my own experience and from some research is that the momentum is still there but it
一切都调到了11级。一旦威胁消失，这并不会立刻消失。你仍然有一种非常高度的身体和情感体验，现在在你的身体里漂浮着，没有太多的目标。所以我认为，从我自己的经验和一些研究来看，似乎发生的一件事是，动力仍然存在，但它
kind of changes the direction. And so now it's directed towards immense relief and inhalation rather than terror. But the physical feeling is not entirely different. Intense terror and intense relief might seem like very different emotions, but they have something in common. They are both intense. The emotional overlap between the two might partly be explained by the fact
改变了方向。所以现在它指向了巨大的解脱和吸气，而不是恐惧。但身体的感觉并不完全不同。强烈的恐惧和强烈的解脱看起来可能非常不同，但它们有一个共同点。它们都很强烈。两者之间的情感重叠可能部分可以用这样一个事实来解释：
that our brain categorizes feelings into two groups. Higher rousal and lower rousal. So, for example, excitement and terror don't look that different in the body, and so it's relatively easy then to switch from one to the other. This might explain why Jamie's group shifted so quickly from screaming to uncontrollable laughter, from terror to euphoria. But it's worth noting something here. The euphoria we feel after a near miss, it's not pure joy.
我们的大脑将感觉分为两类：高唤醒和低唤醒。例如，兴奋和恐惧在身体上看起来并没有太大区别，因此从一种状态切换到另一种状态相对容易。这可能解释了为什么杰米的团队从尖叫迅速转变为无法控制的大笑，从恐惧转变为狂喜。但这里值得注意的一点是：我们在死里逃生后感受到的狂喜，并不是纯粹的快乐。
It is often an unpleasant aftertaste attached to this particular high. It's not just you know the heights of pleasure but there typically is also a sense of it's almost like an after version of dread like wow that was close I really don't want to ever get that close again and and it kind of sticks in your mind even though you're obviously quite pleased that the outcome didn't occur. Can you stay with that idea moment because that idea is so fascinating?
这种特殊的快感往往带有一种令人不快的余味。这不仅仅是快乐的巅峰，通常还有一种感觉，几乎像是恐惧的后续版本，比如“哇，太险了，我真的不想再经历那种险境了”，它会留在你的脑海里，尽管你显然对结果没有发生感到非常高兴。你能保持这个想法片刻吗？因为这个想法太迷人了。
Because simultaneously, we have a sense of elation and perhaps euphoria. But it's not something that we say, this felt euphoric, I want to do it again. When we have these moments, we never sort of say I want to do it again, even though it feels euphoric afterwards, which speaks to what you're talking about, which is the euphoria is tinged in some ways with dread. Absolutely. So, you know, one of the things that's kind of at the core of most people's thinking about emotions
因为同时，我们有一种欣喜若狂甚至狂喜的感觉。但我们不会说：“这感觉很狂喜，我想再来一次。”当我们有这些时刻时，我们从不会说“我想再来一次”，尽管事后感觉很狂喜，这印证了你所说的，即这种狂喜在某种程度上带有恐惧的色彩。绝对是这样。所以，你知道，大多数人对情绪思考的核心之一
is this idea that feeling is for doing. In other words, the emotions, we have emotions because they are motivating, they help us to survive functionally or to be well, in many cases. And so we can only ever guess at the evolutionary roots of specific emotions, but our best guess with that sort of relief is that it is meant to be sort of rewarding in the sense that it's usually thought of as a positive emotion because we didn't have the bad thing happen. We did something right that helped us survive. And so, that's a good thing, but you also probably got way too close for comfort if you're having that feeling.
是“感觉是为了行动”这个想法。换句话说，情绪之所以存在，是因为它们具有激励作用，它们帮助我们在功能上生存或保持健康。在许多情况下，我们只能猜测特定情绪的进化根源，但我们对这种解脱的最佳猜测是，它旨在成为一种奖励，因为它通常被认为是一种积极的情绪，因为坏事没有发生。我们做对了某件事，帮助我们生存了下来。所以，这是一件好事，但如果你有这种感觉，你可能也离危险太近了。
And so, it is adaptive, essentially, for relief to both feel good, reward the thing you did right, but also draw your attention towards the very distinct possibility that it could have gone a different way so that you can avoid such a close call in the future. As kids tell you the phenomenon of relief, she began to realize there was more than one kind of relief. We've looked at the hue that was close kind of relief,
因此，解脱既能让人感觉良好、奖励你做对的事情，又能将你的注意力引向它可能以不同方式发展的明显可能性，以便你在未来避免这种险境，这在本质上是适应性的。当凯特告诉你解脱的现象时，她开始意识到解脱不止一种。我们已经看了那种“呼，太险了”的解脱，
the kind that we often associate with close calls and near misses. But there's also another kind that makes you go, finally, thank heavens. It turns out this form of relief has an entirely different psychological signature. Kate has a story from her own life that reveals this other dimension of relief. Some years ago, she planned a trip with her husband and her parents to Iceland. She was incredibly excited about the trip and didn't want to leave anything to chance. She planned every detail. And as part of the planning, I had been really nagging. I'll confess my husband to confirm that his passport wasn't expired because he hadn't traveled in quite some time. I had
那种我们通常与险境和死里逃生联系在一起的解脱。但还有另一种让你说“终于，谢天谢地”的解脱。事实证明，这种形式的解脱有着完全不同的心理特征。凯特有一个来自她自己生活的故事，揭示了这种解脱的另一个维度。几年前，她计划和丈夫及父母去冰岛旅行。她对这次旅行感到非常兴奋，不想留下任何机会。她计划了每一个细节。作为计划的一部分，我一直在唠叨，我承认，我丈夫确认他的护照没有过期，因为他已经很久没有旅行了。我
traveled more recently overseas. And, you know, just trying to get my goat. He kind of refused to show me his passport. So he knew full well it wasn't expired, but he was sort of enjoying getting me riled up about it. So that had been the state of affairs for a few months. The morning before they fly out of LA, Kate logged on to the airline's website to check in. A message popped up on her screen. This really unusual message that I'd never seen before that said something about passport exploration. And I thought, well, no, this can't be right. I've been very clear about
最近去过海外旅行。而且，你知道，只是为了惹我生气，他拒绝给我看他的护照。所以他很清楚护照没有过期，但他很享受让我为此抓狂。所以这种情况已经持续了几个月。在他们从洛杉矶起飞的前一天早上，凯特登录航空公司网站办理登机手续。屏幕上弹出一个消息。这是一个我从未见过的非常不寻常的消息，上面写着关于护照过期的事情。我想，好吧，不，这不可能，我非常清楚
whose passports are and are not expired. Kate checked her passport for the hundredth time. It wasn't expired. In fact, it wasn't going to expire until three months after her trip. So why was she still getting that computer message? And so I did some hunting around, some fairly or increasingly panic, hunting around, and ran across the very unfortunate piece of information I had missed, which is that many countries, including Iceland, require that you have a passport that is valid for some period of time after your trip, in case you decide to just stay.
谁的护照过期了，谁的没有。凯特第一百次检查了她的护照。它没有过期。事实上，它在旅行结束后三个月才过期。那么为什么她还会收到那个电脑消息呢？所以我做了一些搜寻，一些相当或越来越恐慌的搜寻，并遇到了我错过的一个非常不幸的信息：许多国家，包括冰岛，要求你的护照在旅行结束后必须在一段时间内有效，以防你决定留下来。
A passport that expired three months after the trip? That wasn't long enough. I felt sick. I felt absolutely physically ill. Panic, certainly, but just I think nausea was probably the primary, the primary feeling as it was really starting to dawn on me. What was happening? Kate made a few phone calls, first to her dad. It was like, map, sounds like a problem. Not sure what to tell you. Then to the State Department.
护照在旅行结束后三个月才过期？那时间不够长。我感到恶心。我感到绝对的身体不适。当然是恐慌，但我认为恶心可能是主要的，主要的感觉，因为我真的开始意识到发生了什么。凯特打了几个电话，首先打给她的父亲。他说：“凯特，听起来是个问题。不知道该告诉你什么。”然后打给国务院。
They confirmed Kate had made a mistake. But they also offered some good news. About three hours from Kate's home, there was a State Department office that did same day pass-board renewals. I basically grabbed my purse and got in the car. I was just absolutely frantic with terror that this whole thing was going to fall apart
他们证实凯特犯了一个错误。但他们也提供了一些好消息。在离凯特家大约三个小时路程的地方，有一个国务院办公室可以办理当日护照更新。我基本上抓起钱包就上了车。我当时绝对因为恐惧而疯狂，担心这一切都会泡汤，
and it was all going to be my fault. And I also just could not quite get past the irony that I had been such a pain to my husband about his bath for it. And now this was all happening to me. Kate Drove drove in silence, inching through three plus hours of rush hour traffic. When she got to the State Department office,
而且这全都是我的错。而且我也无法克服这种讽刺：我之前一直因为护照问题折磨我丈夫，而现在这一切都发生在我身上。凯特在沉默中开车，在三个多小时的交通高峰中缓慢前行。当她到达国务院办公室时，
there was a very long line. When she got to the front of that line and turned in her documents to get a new passport, she was sent to wait in another long line. During this period of time, I once again called my father, who is just sort of my first call for most, I don't know, life panic moments. And he had the interesting idea of trying to reach the Icelandic Embassy, which on reflection seems absurd, but seemed
排了很长的队。当她排到队首并交出文件以获取新护照时，她被派去排另一条长队。在这段时间里，我再次给父亲打了电话，他是我大多数，我不知道，生活恐慌时刻的第一个求助对象。他有一个有趣的想法，尝试联系冰岛大使馆，回想起来这似乎很荒谬，但在当时看来
as reasonable as anything at the time. Kate hopped on her phone to find a number for the embassy. It turns out the embassy in LA for Iceland is small such that it is also serves as a recording studio. So I had a few bizarre moments of calling this number and having the person answer, you know, such and such recording studio and he's saying, okay, and I hang up. And then the next time I called, he says, wait, wait, don't hang up. Are you trying to reach the Icelandic embassy? I said, yes, I am. I said, oh no, wait, wait, don't hang up, don't hang up. Are you trying to reach the Icelandic embassy? I said, yes, I am. So don't know, we do that too. We do that too.
和任何事情一样合理。凯特拿起电话查找大使馆的号码。事实证明，冰岛在洛杉矶的大使馆很小，以至于它同时也兼作录音室。所以我有了几次奇怪的经历，拨打这个号码，对方回答说：“某某录音室”，我说：“好的”，然后挂断。下一次我打过去，他说：“等等，等等，别挂断。你是想联系冰岛大使馆吗？”我说：“是的，我是。”我说：“哦不，等等，等等，别挂断，别挂断。你是想联系冰岛大使馆吗？”我说：“是的，我是。”所以不知道，我们也做那个。我们也做那个。
The recording studio slash embassy gave her the number of someone in Washington, DC, which also didn't pan out. But you know, after about, I think it was 10 hours total right before the office closed, they called my name and I had a passport in hand. Compared to the relief she felt not going over the cliff in Norway, Kate did not feel elation or even excitement. It was just exhaustion. I think all systems were just spent at that point and I just wanted to lay down.
录音室兼大使馆给了她一个华盛顿特区某人的号码，但也行不通。但是，你知道，在大约10个小时后，就在办公室关门前，他们叫了我的名字，我拿到了护照。与她在挪威没有掉下悬崖后感受到的解脱相比，凯特没有感到欣喜若狂，甚至没有感到兴奋。只有精疲力竭。我想当时所有的系统都耗尽了，我只想躺下。
Her mind was saying, finally. This feeling of exhausted release fell different from the surge of euphoria that Kate experienced after her drive along a cliffside in Norway. Thank heavens that's over feels different than few. That was close. Heavens that's over feels different than few. That was close. Why do we have two different mechanisms in the brain to experience the same emotion? Do these different responses affect how we remember events, how we respond to similar events in the future? Kate decided to launch an experiment to find out. She recruited volunteers for a study that was ostensibly about music and emotions. We asked them a lot of questions when they first got there, some of which we actually cared about, things like their
她的内心在说：“终于。”这种精疲力竭的释放感与凯特在挪威悬崖边开车后经历的狂喜浪潮感觉不同。“谢天谢地，结束了”的感觉与“呼，太险了”的感觉不同。“谢天谢地，结束了”的感觉与“呼，太险了”的感觉不同。为什么我们大脑中有两种不同的机制来体验同一种情绪？这些不同的反应会影响我们如何记忆事件，以及我们如何应对未来的类似事件吗？凯特决定发起一项实验来找出答案。她招募了志愿者进行一项表面上关于音乐和情绪的研究。当他们第一次到达时，我们问了他们很多问题，其中一些是我们真正关心的，比如他们的
emotional state, and then a lot of kind of distracting things that made them believe we were interested in their take on how music makes you feel. The study was centered around a song. Feelings by Morris Elberts. And this is a very sappy song. Kate and her team divided volunteers into two groups. The first group was told they would have to listen to the song and then sing it as a research assistant recorded the performance. In other words, they were asked to do something extremely awkward and uncomfortable. So that's mimicking essentially or creating. In fact, the experience of what we would call task completion relief. They did the thing and now thank heavens it's over.
情绪状态，然后还有很多分散注意力的东西，让他们相信我们对他们关于音乐如何让你感觉的看法感兴趣。这项研究围绕着一首歌展开：《Feelings》，由莫里斯·阿尔伯特演唱。这是一首非常伤感的歌。凯特和她的团队将志愿者分为两组。第一组被告知他们必须听这首歌，然后唱出来，研究助理会录下表演。换句话说，他们被要求做一些极其尴尬和不舒服的事情。所以这本质上是在模仿或创造我们所说的“任务完成型解脱”。他们完成了任务，现在“谢天谢地，结束了”。
In the second group, the volunteers were told the same thing. Listen to the song, then sing the song on camera, They did the thing and now thank heavens it's over. In the second group, the volunteers were told the same thing. Listen to the song, then sing the song on camera in front of a research assistant. And then lo and behold, the recorder is broken and they won't have to sing after all. It probably goes without saying the recorder was not in fact broken, but that set up the experience we were looking for, which is near-miss relief. So these participants in the study thought they were going to have to do this terrible thing and then were saved in the nick of time from having to do so.
在第二组中，志愿者被告知同样的事情。听这首歌，然后在研究助理面前对着摄像机唱这首歌。然后，瞧，录音机坏了，他们根本不需要唱了。不用说，录音机实际上并没有坏，但这设置了我们正在寻找的体验，即“死里逃生型解脱”。所以这些研究参与者以为他们必须做这件可怕的事情，然后在最后一刻被拯救，免于去做。
The results of the study were consistent across the board. Volunteers who experienced completion relief felt uncomfortable before and during their performance. But what's fascinating is that right afterwards, they moved on quickly with that day. This was something that Kate and her team understood as yet another evolutionary adaptation. If you do something hard or unpleasant and you survive it, there isn't that much of a function to kind of ruminating on what just happened because if you are asked to do it again, you don't necessarily want fresh in your mind how terrible that thing was.
研究结果在各方面都是一致的。经历过“完成型解脱”的志愿者在表演前和表演过程中感到不舒服。但令人着迷的是，事后他们很快就继续过那一天了。这是凯特和她的团队理解为另一种进化适应的东西。如果你做了一些困难或不愉快的事情并且幸存下来，那么反思刚刚发生的事情并没有太大的功能，因为如果你被要求再做一次，你不一定想在脑海中保持那件事有多么可怕。
It's much more functional, we think, to simply experience the kind of positive rewards of satisfaction, feel like it was a job well done or at least done, and that might incentivize you to take on difficult challenges in the future. But the volunteers who experienced the near miss who didn't end up having to sing a
我们认为，简单地体验那种积极的满足感，感觉像是一项工作完成得很好，或者至少是完成了，这可能更有功能性，这可能会激励你在未来承担困难的挑战。但是那些经历了“死里逃生”的志愿者，他们最终没有在陌生人面前唱一首
sappy love song in front of a stranger, they reported something very different. Like Jamie in South Africa and Kate in Norway, these volunteers not only felt elated to have been spared, but spend time afterwards, ruminating on what happened. It seems like when you have a near miss, a close call, it's useful. If rather than just moving on and pretending it never happened, we actually do spend a bit of mental energy thinking through how we can essentially ensure that we don't get that close again. As Kate reflected on her own experiences, as well as the experimental findings, she realized there was an important component of the experience she had not yet studied.
伤感的情歌，他们报告了一些非常不同的东西。就像南非的杰米和挪威的凯特一样，这些志愿者不仅为幸免于难感到欣喜若狂，而且事后花时间反思发生了什么。似乎当你经历了一次死里逃生，一次险境时，这是有用的。如果我们不是直接继续前进并假装它从未发生过，而是真正花一点心理能量思考我们如何从本质上确保我们不会再那么接近危险，那会更好。当凯特反思自己的经历以及实验结果时，她意识到她经历中有一个重要的组成部分她还没有研究过。
Not the part where you go, few, or thank heavens that's over, but the agonizing moments before the arrival of relief. The moments when the car was inching to the edge of the cliff, or the lions began creeping toward the Land Rover. The 10 hours Kate spent in the State Department office unsure about whether she would get the passport in time. One thing I've studied is the idea of bracing for the worst, and it's a very functional form of expectation management that we do when we're waiting for some kind of news where
不是你喊“呼”或“谢天谢地，结束了”的那部分，而是解脱到来之前那令人煎熬的时刻。汽车缓慢驶向悬崖边缘，或者狮子开始向路虎车爬行的时刻。凯特在国务院办公室度过的10个小时，不确定是否能及时拿到护照。我研究的一件事是“为最坏情况做准备”的想法，这是一种非常实用的期望管理形式，当我们等待某种消息时，我们会
we embrace pessimism and really consider the possible negative outcomes so that we're prepared. As the world deals with a seemingly endless coronavirus pandemic, many of us have become experts in this kind of waiting. Can being worried about the coronavirus make you more? It will be months before the general public gets access to this vaccine. The recipe for anxiety and depression, ABC's aerial recipe. It's a basic, truly primal instinct, and it too is contagious. When we come back, the psychology of bracing for the worst and new psychological insights on how to cope with dread and uncertainty.
拥抱悲观主义，真正考虑可能的负面结果，以便我们做好准备。随着世界应对看似无休止的冠状病毒大流行，我们许多人已经成为这种等待的专家。担心冠状病毒会让你更多吗？普通大众获得这种疫苗还需要几个月的时间。焦虑和抑郁的处方，ABC的空中处方。这是一种基本的、真正原始的本能，它也是会传染的。当我们回来时，将探讨为最坏情况做准备的心理学，以及关于如何应对恐惧和不确定性的新心理学见解。
Before we can experience relief, we invariably have to go through a period of waiting. As many of us have learned, this can be uncomfortable, distressing. It can make sleep difficult, distract us from work, and leave us anxious. Psychologist Kate Sweeney has studied the experience of waiting. She's examined people who've developed strategies to wait well and others who crumble under the pressure of uncertainty. Some of her insights also stem from a lengthy personal experience of being on edge.
在我们体验到解脱之前，总是不得不经历一段等待期。正如我们许多人所了解的那样，这可能会让人感到不适和痛苦。它会让人难以入睡，使我们无法专心工作，并让我们感到焦虑。心理学家凯特·斯威尼（Kate Sweeney）研究了等待的体验。她考察了那些制定了良好等待策略的人，以及那些在不确定性的压力下崩溃的人。她的一些见解也源于她自己长期处于紧张状态的个人经历。
her insights also stem from a lengthy personal experience of being on edge. During her sixth and final year of grad school, Kate began applying for research jobs at universities. Those jobs are incredibly hard to get there, just not very many of them and there's lots of people who want them. So I knew it was a long shot, but I wanted to give it a try. Kate spent most of the summer and early fall on the onerous tasks of preparing and completing job applications. In the fall, she submitted her applications and held her breath. Ultimately, I had some, you know, initial good luck, so I got five different interviews. From the beginning of November to the beginning of December,
她的见解也源于她自己长期处于紧张状态的个人经历。在研究生院的第六年，也就是最后一年，凯特开始申请大学的研究工作。这些工作非常难找，职位本来就不多，而想要这些职位的人却很多。所以我知道这希望渺茫，但我还是想试一试。凯特在夏天和初秋的大部分时间里，都在忙于准备和完成繁琐的求职申请。秋天，她提交了申请，然后屏息以待。最终，我运气不错，获得了五个不同的面试机会。从11月初到12月初，
Kate flew all across North America, interviewing at the University of Miami at Ohio, University of Iowa, the University of British Columbia, University of Illinois at Chicago, and then last at University of California Riverside. The hiring process for an academic job involves much more than just an interview. You often have to give a prepared lecture, have detailed discussions with students and faculty, and engage in extended Q&A sessions. It can be grueling. So I was exhausted by the end of it and ready for it to be over, but I had had a good experience and I was feeling pretty good about my chances. But as the answers rolled in,
凯特飞遍了北美各地，先后在俄亥俄州的迈阿密大学、爱荷华大学、不列颠哥伦比亚大学、芝加哥伊利诺伊大学面试，最后是在加州大学河滨分校。学术工作的招聘过程不仅仅是面试那么简单。你通常需要发表一场准备好的演讲，与学生和教职员工进行详细的讨论，并参加长时间的问答环节。这可能非常折磨人。所以面试结束时我精疲力竭，只想快点结束，但我有很好的体验，对自己的机会也感觉相当不错。但随着结果陆续传来，
Kate's positive attitude started to falter. So this will be a parade of failure. So University of Iowa, I didn't hear from from quite a while and then ultimately found out that the position had been offered to someone else and that they had accepted, I believe, or if they didn't in any case did not come to me. It was the same for all the other universities she applied to, except for one. The University of California Riverside. It was within two weeks after the interview just before the holiday break. I got the call that I was the second choice, so it could have been worse. The reason the university called to tell her that she was the second choice was that the candidate
凯特的积极态度开始动摇。这简直是一场失败的游行。爱荷华大学那边，我等了很久都没有消息，最后发现职位已经提供给了别人，而且我相信他们已经接受了，或者即使他们没接受，无论如何也没有轮到我。她申请的其他所有大学也是如此，只有一个例外。加州大学河滨分校。面试后不到两周，就在假期开始前。我接到电话说我是第二人选，所以情况本可能更糟。大学打电话告诉她她是第二人选的原因是，那位
who was the first choice had said she needed time to figure things out. The university promised Kate to be back in touch once they heard back from the other candidate, which meant Kate was left in a state of limbo. She was going to have to wait. So we now set off into holiday break with her making a decision, me having no control over either the decision or the timeline and knowing that I would have at least a month to wait. Kate's dress manifested in ways many of us can relate to. I would wake up just naturally in the middle of the night, but rather than easing back into sleep,
第一人选说她需要时间考虑清楚。大学承诺凯特，一旦收到另一位候选人的回复，就会与她联系，这意味着凯特陷入了悬而未决的状态。她不得不等待。于是我们现在进入了假期，她要做出决定，而我对决定或时间表毫无控制权，并且知道我至少要等上一个月。凯特的压力以许多人都能感同身受的方式表现出来。我会自然地在半夜醒来，但与其慢慢入睡，
my mind would seize upon some worry about what would be fall me if this job didn't work out and trying to play the odds of whether it would come my way, but it definitely made sleeping soundly pretty challenging. When she wasn't spiraling into doubt, she would bargain with herself, trying to find a reason to not want the job. She told herself it would be better to find a postdoctoral job,
我的大脑会抓住一些担忧，比如如果这份工作没成我该怎么办，并试图权衡它是否会落到我头上，但这确实让安稳入睡变得相当困难。当她没有陷入怀疑的漩涡时，她会与自己讨价还价，试图找到一个不想这份工作的理由。她告诉自己，找一份博士后工作会更好，
a temporary position that's more like a fellowship. I think more than catastrophizing, I was looking for any way out of the absolute torture of uncertainty that I was experiencing. After Christmas, Kate continued to wait and wait and wait. Finally, in January, she heard back from the school. Around 505 on a Friday, I believe. I got an email from the chair of the department at the time.
那是一个更像研究员的临时职位。我想比起灾难化想象，我是在寻找任何能摆脱我所经历的那种绝对不确定性折磨的方法。圣诞节后，凯特继续等待，等待，再等待。终于，在一月份，她收到了学校的回复。我相信是在周五下午5点05分左右。我收到了当时系主任的电子邮件。
I'm sure just not thinking quite clearly on a Friday that this was going to set me into a tailspin. But he said something to the effect of, I have some news. I think you'll be pleased. I'll call you tomorrow. I remember I had plans to hang out with some friends from my graduate program, and I just called them and said I'm useless.
我敢肯定，在周五下午，他并没有想清楚这会让我陷入混乱。但他说了类似这样的话：我有一些消息，我想你会高兴的。我明天给你打电话。我记得我当时计划和研究生项目的一些朋友出去玩，我直接给他们打电话说我没用了。
I can't, I just have to go to sleep as early as I can and hope for tomorrow to come. The night lasted forever. And then? On the next day, the rest of my life sort of began. The head of the department called to tell her that the other candidate had decided not to take the job and that they wanted to offer the position to Kate. I think I knew in that moment that the cool thing to do would be to, you know, play koi like I had lots of other options, but I did not do that. In the least, I think I exclaimed with Joy and he said, oh, good.
我不能，我必须尽早去睡觉，希望明天快点到来。那个夜晚漫长得仿佛没有尽头。然后呢？第二天，我的余生开始了。系主任打电话告诉她，另一位候选人决定不接受这份工作，他们想把这个职位提供给凯特。我想在那一刻我知道，最酷的做法是，你知道，装作若无其事，好像我还有很多其他选择一样，但我根本没那样做。我想我当时高兴地惊呼起来，他说，哦，太好了。
So, so, so you're, you're enthusiastic about taking it and then I, you know, calm down right away and said, well, you know, I, of of course I'll need to hear the details, but I think I was probably doing a dance of joy as I was saying that. The experience of having to wait for something is universal, but surprisingly, Kate found very little research had been done on it, and almost no research had been done on how people could manage the anxiety and uncertainty of waiting. You know, I think one of the things is it is difficult to study because so often these waiting periods are, I mean, they are by definition, in fact, temporary. And so it does take some pretty
所以，所以，所以你，你很热衷于接受它，然后我，你知道，立刻冷静下来，说，嗯，你知道，我，我当然需要听听细节，但我说这话的时候可能正在跳着快乐的舞蹈。等待某事的经历是普遍的，但令人惊讶的是，凯特发现关于这方面的研究很少，而且几乎没有人研究人们如何管理等待带来的焦虑和不确定性。你知道，我认为其中一个原因是它很难研究，因为这些等待期通常，我的意思是，事实上，根据定义，它们是暂时的。所以这确实需要研究人员付出一些相当
significant creative work on the part of researchers to figure out how best To create those experiences if you're doing so for example in the lab or find them out in the wild and actually catch them as they're happening In other words one reason it's hard to study waiting is that waiting tends to be unpredictable You don't always know that your aim for an extended period of waiting until you're actually in it. That made it difficult to study using the experimental tools of modern psychology. So what we were really, you know, looking for was a waiting period we could study practically that was long enough to watch some of these processes unfold that we were interested in and that had fairly high stakes. After brainstorming, kids' team identified the perfect group to study.
重大的创造性工作，才能弄清楚如果要在实验室中进行研究，或者在现实生活中发现并捕捉这些正在发生的等待体验，该如何最好地创造这些体验。换句话说，等待难以研究的一个原因是等待往往是不可预测的。你并不总是知道自己会经历一段漫长的等待，直到你真正身处其中。这使得利用现代心理学的实验工具进行研究变得困难。所以我们真正寻找的是一个我们可以实际研究的等待期，它足够长，可以观察到我们感兴趣的一些过程，而且风险相当高。经过头脑风暴，凯特的团队确定了完美的实验对象。
California law students waiting on the results of their bar exam. Typically in California, most people take the exam in late July, and then they wait. The wait is considerably longer than it is in many other states. It's for very long months. They all get their results at the same time. It's posted online whether they passed or failed in late November. So they can all go online and check. And in the interim, of course, they're all hearing
等待律师资格考试结果的加州法学院学生。通常在加州，大多数人在7月下旬参加考试，然后等待。这个等待时间比许多其他州要长得多。长达四个月。他们都在同一时间收到结果。11月下旬，考试结果会在网上公布，显示他们是否通过。所以他们都可以上网查询。当然，在此期间，他们都在听
from all their friends who took the Barg Xam and other states and are already getting their results, which simply, I think, adds to the torture, particularly because in California, we have one of the lowest pass rates for the bar exam in the United States. And it's also an incredibly stressful waiting period for the folks who endure it, given that their professional future essentially rides on this exam, and it is pretty hard to pass. Now that they had the perfect group to study, Kate and her colleagues came up with a research plan. We were interested in whether waiting has kind of a shape to it. Is there any predictability to when waiting is the hardest and when it might be a little bit easier? And we've found
其他州参加律师考试的朋友的消息，他们已经收到了结果，我认为这只会增加折磨，特别是因为在加州，我们的律师考试通过率是美国最低的之一。对于那些经历它的人来说，这也是一个压力极大的等待期，因为他们的职业未来基本上取决于这次考试，而且通过考试相当困难。现在他们有了完美的实验对象，凯特和她的同事们制定了一个研究计划。我们对等待是否有一种形状很感兴趣。等待最艰难的时候和可能稍微容易一点的时候是否有规律可循？我们发现
in that context and lots of others, it seems to be hardest at the beginning and the end and a little easier in the middle. Kate was also interested in finding out how people with different temperaments reacted to the stress of waiting. So she launched another study. She followed a group of women as they waited for the results of a biopsy for breast cancer. It's you know not an easy study to run as you can imagine you know we're asking for time and you know kind of emotional attention from someone who's having a probably not great
在这种背景下以及许多其他背景下，它似乎在开始和结束时最难，而在中间稍微容易一些。凯特还对不同性格的人如何应对等待的压力感兴趣。于是她发起了另一项研究。她跟踪了一组等待乳腺癌活检结果的女性。正如你可以想象的那样，这不是一项容易进行的研究，你知道，我们要求一个可能正在经历人生中不太美好的一天的人贡献时间和情感关注。
day in their life. And so we try to get as much as we can from what little time we have with them. Before the women had a biopsy, Kate and her team tried to figure out each woman's baseline emotional state by asking questions about their personality, health history, and coping strategies. Then the week after the procedure, they're checking on the women to see how they were dealing with uncertainty. We're really interested in just figuring out
所以我们尽量从与她们相处的有限时间里获得尽可能多的信息。在女性进行活检之前，凯特和她的团队试图通过询问关于她们的性格、健康史和应对策略的问题，来弄清楚每位女性的基线情绪状态。然后在手术后的一周，他们会跟进这些女性，看看她们是如何应对不确定性的。我们真的很想弄清楚
who is more resilient to that experience and why, what are they doing right? What kids' team found was that there are some people, especially those who tend to be optimistic in their day-to-day lives, who are much more comfortable with the uncertainty of waiting. One of the things that is most consistent is, if you generally expect that the thing you're waiting for
谁对这种经历更有韧性，为什么，她们做对了什么？凯特的团队发现，有些人，特别是那些在日常生活中倾向于乐观的人，对等待的不确定性要舒服得多。最一致的事情之一是，如果你通常预期你所等待的事情
is going to turn out well, waiting is a whole lot easier. Having said that, that makes you feel good while you're waiting, but if the unfortunate turn of events occurs, that the outcome isn't what you hope for, being so optimistic as you're waiting can really set you up for some pretty shattering distress and disappointment. And so, unfortunately, one of the things that we've really revealed in our research and haven't been able to quite reconcile in terms of how to advise people is that a good waiting period will often mean underwhelming good news and potentially shattering bad news,
会有一个好的结果，等待就会容易得多。话虽如此，这会让你在等待时感觉良好，但如果发生了不幸的转折，结果不如你所愿，那么在等待时过于乐观真的会让你在面对随后的毁灭性痛苦和失望时受到重创。所以，不幸的是，我们在研究中真正揭示的一点，也是我们在如何建议人们方面无法完全调和的一点是，一个好的等待期往往意味着令人失望的好消息和潜在的毁灭性坏消息，
whereas a really worrisome waiting period means elation in the face of good news and potentially shattering bad news, whereas a really worrisome waiting period means elation in the face of good news and maybe a little less of a shattering experience with bad news. It's not quite clear that you can split the difference. In other words, you can choose to be optimistic at the front end and run the risk of feeling let down at the end, or choose to be pessimistic at the front end, have a miserable time as you wait, but limit the emotional downside of bad news. That doesn't sound very helpful. It sounds like you just have to pick your poison.
而一个非常令人担忧的等待期则意味着面对好消息时的狂喜，以及面对坏消息时可能稍微不那么毁灭性的体验。目前还不清楚你是否能折中。换句话说，你可以选择在前期保持乐观，并冒着最后感到失望的风险；或者选择在前期保持悲观，在等待时度过一段痛苦的时光，但限制坏消息带来的情感负面影响。这听起来不太有帮助。听起来你只能两害相权取其轻。
But keep things to finding, does contain an important insight. If I had to give advice about balancing the kind of trade-offs of distress while waiting or distress after, it would probably be all about the timing. So one of the things that we know from our research is that, for example, bracing for the worst is good at the moment of truth, whatever that might mean, if that's minutes or hours or days, but close to that moment where you're going to find out the outcome. Put another way, optimism prepares you for waiting, but pessimism prepares you for bad news. So try to stay positive, be as optimistic as you can, as long as you can, and then kind of
但凯特的发现确实包含了一个重要的见解。如果我必须就平衡等待时的痛苦与等待后的痛苦之间的权衡给出建议，那可能完全取决于时机。所以我们从研究中知道的一点是，例如，为最坏的情况做准备在真相大白的时刻是有效的，无论这意味着什么，如果是几分钟、几小时或几天，但要接近你即将知道结果的那个时刻。换句话说，乐观让你为等待做好准备，而悲观让你为坏消息做好准备。所以尽量保持积极，尽可能长时间地保持乐观，然后
grapple with the potential for bad news towards the end of the wait in hopes that that will buy you that that buffer from bad news and that elation over good news. Kate has developed an entire toolbox of strategies like this. Another has to do with the feeling she experienced as she was waiting to hear back about that job. A loss of control. As I've thought about what makes waiting so hard and what makes it different from other kinds of stressful experiences, I've come to the conclusion and we now have some data to support this, that it's the combination of not knowing what's coming, being uncertain and not having control, so not being able to do anything about your future or your outcome.
在等待的最后阶段应对坏消息的可能性，希望这能为你提供缓冲，让你在面对好消息时感到狂喜。凯特开发了一整套这样的策略工具箱。另一个策略与她在等待那份工作回复时的感受有关。一种失控感。当我思考是什么让等待变得如此艰难，以及它与其他压力体验有何不同时，我得出了一个结论，我们现在也有一些数据支持这一点，那就是不知道未来会发生什么、不确定性以及没有控制权——即无法对你的未来或结果做任何事情——这两者的结合才是最难的。
And it's those two things that are really difficult in combination. So if you can grab hold of a little control over your fate by at least being planful about what you'll do if the bad news comes, that can ameliorate a little bit that a challenge of not feeling like you have control. Kate did a version of this when she was waiting to find out about the job at UC Riverside. Maybe I don't want to start a faculty position right away. Maybe it just needs better if I started off with post-doc. There's another benefit to thinking this way. It allows you to shift perspective on what the bad news means.
正是这两件事结合在一起才非常困难。所以，如果你能通过至少对坏消息到来时该怎么做进行规划，从而掌握一点对自己命运的控制权，那就能稍微减轻那种感觉自己没有控制权的挑战。凯特在等待加州大学河滨分校的工作结果时就做了类似的事情。也许我不想马上开始教职工作。也许如果我从博士后开始会更好。这种思考方式还有另一个好处。它让你改变对坏消息意味着什么的看法。
It allows you to see that even bad news can have an upside. So, one of the things that we know from research on trauma is that people who are able to find some sort of silver lining, some kind of benefit in something, you know, bad that happens to them, a loss or a trauma, they tend to be better off. If you can figure out something good that came of something bad, that's a typically good coping technique for well-being. But in my lab, we study waiting, and so I wondered if maybe it's the case that we can kind of set up those silver linings in advance so that they're ready and waiting for us when or if the bad news comes. To test this, Kate and her team asked the
它让你看到即使是坏消息也可能有积极的一面。所以，我们从创伤研究中知道的一点是，那些能够找到某种一线希望，在发生在他们身上的坏事、损失或创伤中找到某种益处的人，往往过得更好。如果你能找出坏事中产生的好事，这通常是一种很好的应对幸福感的技巧。但在我的实验室里，我们研究等待，所以我怀疑我们是否可以在坏消息到来之前就预先设定好那些一线希望，以便在坏消息到来时它们已经准备好等待我们。为了测试这一点，凯特和她的团队询问了
group of women waiting on their biopsy results if they could see any kind of silver lining in finding out that they would require treatment. That was a gentle way of asking, is there any upside to finding out that you have cancer? And what we found is that almost 75% of our sample said, yes, they could, they did not yet have a diagnosis, but they could imagine seeing some kind of silver lining if they found out that they had cancer. And their silver linings, when we inquired about them, ranged pretty broadly.
那组等待活检结果的女性，她们是否能从得知自己需要治疗的结果中看到任何一线希望。这是一种委婉的问法：得知自己患有癌症有什么积极的一面吗？我们发现，几乎75%的样本说，是的，她们可以。她们当时还没有确诊，但如果她们发现自己患有癌症，她们可以想象看到某种一线希望。当我们询问她们的一线希望时，范围非常广泛。
Some of them were more social, so things like serving as a role model for their daughters, being more connected to friends and family, but then also some were more kind of personal, like appreciating life more or appreciating the time that they spent with family more or thinking more carefully about their health. So the kinds of silver linings people identify are really wide-ranging and of course depend on the context, but people do seem very readily able to identify those silver linings even
其中一些更偏向社交，比如成为女儿的榜样，与朋友和家人联系更紧密；但也有一些更偏向个人，比如更珍惜生命，更珍惜与家人共度的时间，或者更仔细地思考自己的健康。所以人们确定的一线希望种类非常广泛，当然也取决于具体情况，但人们似乎确实非常容易在
in advance. So again, be optimistic at the front end of the waiting period and pessimistic as you get close to the moment of truth. Come up with plans on how you can adapt if the worst case scenario comes to pass, and think in advance about the silver linings of bad news. All of these strategies of course are needed now more than ever. I feel that over the last several months, the entire world in some ways has been living your research. And I'm wondering if you can just talk a moment about the global experience of waiting and holding one's breath in the context of the COVID-19 pandemic. once breath in the context of the COVID-19 pandemic.
提前识别出这些一线希望。所以，再次强调，在等待期的前期保持乐观，在接近真相大白的时刻保持悲观。想好如果最坏的情况发生时你该如何适应，并提前思考坏消息中的一线希望。当然，所有这些策略现在比以往任何时候都更需要。我觉得在过去的几个月里，全世界在某种程度上都在经历你的研究。我想知道你能不能谈谈在新冠疫情背景下，全球等待和屏息以待的体验。
I absolutely agree that we are all in a sort of collective moment of uncertainty and very stressful uncertainty. It's different from some of the things I've studied in a way that I think makes it extra challenging, which is that it's open-ended. So if you take the bar exam, you know that, you know, November 25th or whatever, the result will be there. If you get a biopsy, you know your doctor is calling you in a week. With COVID-19, we're all in this suspension essentially. And that, it seems, makes waiting a lot harder in some ways because you can't plan really and you can't sort of put your mind on hold and just wait it out till the results come because there is no result coming exactly. And so it's, you know's isolating us from other people, which is not good for well-being. It's disrupting our schedules.
我完全同意我们都处于一种集体的不确定性时刻，而且是非常令人压力的不确定性。它与我研究过的一些事情不同，我认为这让它格外具有挑战性，那就是它是开放式的。所以如果你参加律师考试，你知道，11月25日或无论哪一天，结果就会出来。如果你做活检，你知道你的医生会在一周内给你打电话。而对于新冠疫情，我们基本上都处于这种悬浮状态。这似乎在某些方面让等待变得更加困难，因为你无法真正规划，也无法让你的大脑暂停，只是等待结果出来，因为并没有一个确切的结果即将到来。所以，你知道，它将我们与其他人隔离开来，这对幸福感不利。它打乱了我们的日程安排。
And so I think we are not coping especially well. That said, we have a little bit of data that are kind of hot off the presses. From a study we ran, a survey that we sent out in China in February of how people were feeling and to some extent how they were coping. And we found a few interesting things in short, the thing that seemed to be the most helpful,
所以我认为我们应对得不是特别好。话虽如此，我们有一些刚出炉的数据。来自我们进行的一项研究，我们在二月份在中国发送了一份调查，询问人们的感受以及他们在某种程度上是如何应对的。我们发现了一些有趣的事情，简而言之，似乎最有帮助的事情，
especially if you were in quarantine during that period of time, was to find good distractions. In other words, get into a state of flow where you are fully absorbed in some kind of challenging activity in a way that really gets you out of your head and helps time pass quickly. That seems to be maybe the best strategy in that kind of moment. Kate found in her survey in Wuhan that experiencing a sense of flow where people forgot about the pandemic because they were deeply engaged with some other activity. This was associated with significant improvements in well-being.
特别是如果你在那段时间处于隔离状态，就是找到好的消遣。换句话说，进入一种心流状态，你完全沉浸在某种具有挑战性的活动中，这能真正让你摆脱思绪，帮助时间过得很快。在那样的时刻，这似乎是最好的策略。凯特在武汉的调查中发现，体验到一种心流感，即人们因为深度参与其他活动而忘记了疫情。这与幸福感的显著改善有关。
If those folks in quarantine said they were experiencing flow, they looked just like their non-quarantine counterparts in terms of well-being. So, you know, whatever people were doing to find flow, I suspect it just sort of made the time pass faster and more pleasantly in a way that didn't create quite the sense of claustrophobia that quarantine might otherwise create. So what should you do to achieve this ideal state? Kate has devised a simple question to help people figure out how to reach a state of flow. So in fact when I'm helping people identify their own flow states, one way I do that is what is the thing you know you can't start if you have to leave the house in 15 minutes or a half an hour because you will lose track of time. So that's such a baked in part of the flow experience that when time is the enemy because you were just waiting for some kind of news to arrive, it's going to make that happen faster at least in your own perception. assumption.
如果那些处于隔离状态的人说他们正在体验心流，那么在幸福感方面，他们看起来和那些没有隔离的人一样。所以，你知道，无论人们在做什么来寻找心流，我怀疑它只是让时间过得更快、更愉快，以一种不会产生隔离可能带来的那种幽闭恐惧感的方式。那么你应该怎么做才能达到这种理想状态呢？凯特设计了一个简单的问题来帮助人们弄清楚如何达到心流状态。事实上，当我帮助人们识别他们自己的心流状态时，我使用的一种方法是：如果你必须在15分钟或半小时内离开家，你有什么事情是你知道自己不能开始做的，因为你会忘记时间？这就是心流体验中根深蒂固的一部分，所以当时间是敌人，因为你只是在等待某种消息到来时，这会让它发生得更快，至少在你自己的感知中是这样。
For those of us who want desperately to be out in the world, seeing friends and loved ones, time is the enemy. We stare at the clock and then stare some more. We bargain against the pandemic in our own heads and fantasize about what we will do when it's over. It sometimes feels like the past year has been one long psychology experiment. One thing I found useful at times like this is to imagine we actually are in a psychology experiment.
对于我们这些迫切想要走出去，见到朋友和亲人的人来说，时间是敌人。我们盯着时钟，然后又盯着看。我们在脑海中与疫情讨价还价，幻想疫情结束后我们会做什么。有时感觉过去的一年就像一场漫长的心理学实验。在这样的时刻，我发现有用的一件事是想象我们确实身处一场心理学实验中。
But instead of thinking of ourselves as the guinea pigs, it's helpful to think of ourselves as the guinea pigs, it's helpful to think of ourselves as the scientists. Instead of looking at the world with frustration, turn the tables and look at things with curiosity. Ask yourself why you feel the way you do. Tweak your daily routines and see if they make a difference in how you feel. A pandemic is a useful reminder that there are big, powerful things in our lives that we cannot change. But that doesn't mean we are powerless.
但与其把自己看作小白鼠，不如把自己看作科学家，这会有所帮助。与其带着沮丧看待世界，不如转换视角，带着好奇心去看待事物。问问自己为什么会有这种感觉。调整你的日常作息，看看它们是否会对你的感受产生影响。疫情是一个有用的提醒，提醒我们生活中存在着我们无法改变的巨大而强大的事物。但这并不意味着我们无能为力。
We always have the power to change how we respond. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Midro-Amedia is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarell, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boye is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our run sun hero for this episode is Dan Osset. Dan is chief operating officer of Stitcher Media. For many months in 2020, Dan and I explored what it would be like for Hidden Brain to work with Stitcher as a distribution partner for our podcast. We went back and forth with different proposals and counter proposals. During all the waiting, I was always struck by
我们始终有权改变我们的应对方式。《Hidden Brain》由Hidden Brain Media制作。Midro-Amedia是我们独家的广告销售合作伙伴。我们的音频制作团队包括Bridget McCarthy、Laura Quarell、Autumn Barnes和Andrew Chadwick。Tara Boye是我们的执行制片人。我是《Hidden Brain》的执行编辑。本期节目的幕后英雄是Dan Osset。Dan是Stitcher Media的首席运营官。在2020年的许多个月里，Dan和我探讨了《Hidden Brain》与Stitcher作为我们播客分发合作伙伴合作会是什么样子。我们反复交流了不同的提案和反提案。在所有的等待过程中，我一直对
Dan's intelligence and his emotional intelligence. He helps set up the working relationship between our companies that shapes so much of the work we do every day. If I was less selfish, I would recommend Dan as a diplomat to solve thorny international problems, but that would mean I wouldn't get to work with him. Thanks Dan. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. I'm Shankar Vedantum. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Dan的智慧和情商印象深刻。他帮助建立了我们公司之间的工作关系，这种关系塑造了我们每天所做的大部分工作。如果我没那么自私，我会推荐Dan作为外交官去解决棘手的国际问题，但这将意味着我无法与他共事。谢谢你，Dan。想了解更多《Hidden Brain》的内容，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。我是Shankar Vedantum。下周见。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。